Він насмілився критикувати політику Кремля в Сирії.
Тепер репортер Павло Нікулін ризикує свободою.
Я відчинив двері й побачив, що на порозі стоять
двоє поліцейських. У кожного рука на кобурі
лежить. І двоє в цивільному.
Він працював у новинах на державному телеканалі.
Аж поки його не звільнили. Тепер
Дмитро Скоробутов розповідає
про внутрішню кухню російського ТВ.
Щоб картинка була правильною... І, звичайно, все це
модерується. Отримували інструкції, вказівки,
заборони... Державне телебачення не може
показати, що в державі є проблеми.
Вони належали до протилежних таборів.
Тепер їм обом загрожує небезпека. Журналістів, які,
як Нікулін, проводять розслідування,
у Москві - одиниці. Тих, хто піднімає
табуйовані теми: порушення прав людини,
знущання в армії, тероризм.
Після того, як Нікулін взяв інтерв'ю у колишнього
бойовика "Ісламської держави", ним зацікавилася
ФСБ за статтею про "виправдання тероризму".
Вилучили 40 екземплярів ось конкретно цього
випуску. Нічого пов'язаного з Сирією, тероризмом
там немає... Їм не сподобалося просто, що тут
чорна обкладинка.
Ось тут, на державному телеканалі "Росія",
працював Дмитро Скоробутов – шеф-редактором
програми "Вести". Він розповів, що одного разу
його побив п'яний колега. Дмитро вирішив
шукати правди в суді, але керівництво каналу хотіло
приховати цей інцидент. Тому Дмитра звільнили.
Тепер він воює з системою, частиною якої сам був
багато років.
Як редактор я щовечора отримував стоп-списки…
Рядок ембарго –  те, що ми не даємо в ефір:
прізвища, події. Щодо "квітневих протестів":
я спеціально почав відслідковувати усі ці новини.
Нічого не було десь півтора тижні, і наприкінці
другого тижня в підсумковій програмі дуже обтічно
показали: вийшли діти, погаласували, ой-ой,
який непорядок. Ані Навального, ані власне
мотивації людей, які вийшли на вулиці
ста двох міст чи скільки їх...
18 березня в Росії відбудуться вибори і багато хто
очікує маніпуляцій. Але про них мас-медіа,
які контролюються владою, не повідомлять.
Адже росіяни повинні отримати бездоганну
картинку чесних виборів. Чиновники борються
з будь-якою критикою системи, тобто опозицією.
Ромкомнагляд – це ще один механізм,
з одного боку безглуздий, а з іншого - нещадний,
який заважає нам жити. Який під маскою турботи,
наприклад, про дітей, забороняє щось публікувати.
Телебачення – найважливіше джерело інформації
в Росії. Навіть серед молоді.
Більше половини глядачів віком від 18 до 24 років
віддають перевагу новинам Першого каналу
державного телебачення. Хоча в Росії держава
контролює майже всі телеканали. І перетворила їх
на найважливіший інструмент пропаганди,
розповідають люди,
знайомі з роботою ЗМІ зсередини.
Адвокатка мені також спершу не вірила.
Казала, Діма, ви перебільшуєте, ВГТРК  -
не настільки впливова компанія, щоб блокувати,
скажімо, суди. Але коли нам учетверте
відмовили приймати позов, вона сказала: гм,
відбувається щось не те.
Те, як правоохоронні органі дозволяють собі
поводитися з журналістами – не допускати їх
до судів, затримувати на мітингах, приходити до них
із обшуками, це ж не перший обшук у журналіста
за якимись кримінальними справами, - свідчить
про те, що вони нас мають ні за що.
Не думаю, що життя журналістів у Росії
колись покращиться. На жаль, ми живемо в реаліях,
що коли приходиш в цю професію, то мусиш
приймати той факт, що тебе можуть убити.
У Павла Нікуліна та Дмитра Скоробутова
дуже різні історії, але їхні долі - два боки
однієї медалі. У нинішній Росії журналіст повинен
або підлаштуватися і тримати рот на замку,
або шукати собі іншу, безпечнішу професію.
Адже, як часто говорили в радянській Росії,
"хто не з нами, той проти нас".